[__] week this guy hadn't washed his
hands but he who themselves oh yeah this
[__] was high-powered I was crying
[Music]
because it took me the emotional depth
of love that's why it was [__] good I
brought the other half all my smoke yes
I slept in five I had some minute buddy
give a [__] jack
[Music]
and I was that Kentucky green [__] that
Kentucky bluegrass will [__] you up
there's that good weed for [__] years
in Kentucky I got some weed a cup 20
years ago I was [__] strong good floor
and then good grass and I grown up in
the mountains will you [__] not you
know what some do with no feet and a
banjo
they love [__] a little juice and
heat as he told me you know I get myself
a new palace
[Music]
who's on fire Jew on fire
that was I'm fine [__] get ready
to go if you have 18
get the [__] off this thing you don't
belong on heat a little [__] go
to homework
look a minute go through homework you
little [__]
you got a C in [__] science fine it's
like knowing one last night this mother
[__] bleeding jigs that one thank God
the first game he hasn't jinxed all year
we're back [__] it's all over
gret tell grandma to get the [__] the
chemo pills we're gonna give them a shot
tonight yeah I'm saying a couple chemo
pills and a [__] beer forget about it
you'll see the devil and his [__]
cousin
it's Monday night who gives a [__] what
the date is you're here [__]
we got hey-zeus Trejo on here we got the
Christ killer with a Bonica it's all
over for you [__] tonight we got
two different types of weed we got the
[__] hardcore and we got this [__]
I don't even know I can't see without my
glasses
classic OG we got the big bag the big
bag brand-new look at this you could
smell it from the [__] screen it
smells like the first chicky of a finger
bang smell that [__] look at that
little red [__] in there look at that
black chick red [__] you see I'm saying
it never ends they [__] anyway
and we also got you know we we don't go
lightly we don't go lightly BAM it's
nobody's fault but mine gonna get some
gist B to come over here what's those
chicks that play those things belly
dances whatever the [__] they are let's
do this [__] do this [__] do this [__]
do this [__]
don't forget tap I love you there's a
mass killer down there he's killing
chickens he hasn't killed one [__]
chicken but he killed three black people
you see I'm sayin things are bad all
over racism [__] kill the
chicken leave the black people alone
anyway I'm here I'm quit
I want to thank the people from
Lexington that came out this weekend
[__] tremendous I love you
[__] look at this man look at
that breaking out of that [__]
like Rick James oh [__]
eighty-four straight from Buffalo
jumping up and down with white chicks
give them xanaxs I like Cosby and nobody
said nothing Rick James was slinging
dick
Sinatra was slinging dick and who gets
in trouble Harvey Weinstein is insane
they always put that thing out the Jew
never ends his [__] and he's one of
those cattle ballistic Jews Harvey
Weinstein that guy ate the yarmulke you
know I'm saying he don't give a [__]
jack everybody got a little Harvey
Weinstein let me I'm saying all these
[__] from [__] if you're Brad
Pitt you're still gonna tell a chick hey
listen I'll get you an army movie suck
my dick you you show those little ugly
chicks and snatch what I think they were
there for they all suck wet [__] dick
and he got them a little role in the
movies I'm saying see uncle Joey
dropping knowledge on you at [__] 8
o'clock at night on a Monday night you
don't even need to watch either figure
out all your [__] gossip is [__]
we're going for another one here look at
this bleep thinks he's out of the weeds
you don't know I got three more in my
pocket we're going three apiece tonight
oh [__]
[Music]
look at that it looks like a snipe
tremendous see something sometimes you
gotta be this nut sometimes you gotta
the TAC thing that looks like snot
that's how it's not that's how you this
much
just hold that [__] back and
that little snot [__] hook oh hang on
to your Libyan yeah how do you think
those nuts hang on to your nose they got
a little hook that hook is crunchy is
[__] yeah I'm saying you bread that
little hook it's all you never had fried
boogers
I think they invented fried green
tomatoes that's they just drew
everything away let's do boogers nice
new toenails and they settled on [__]
Tomatoes [__] who the [__] you
think you're dealing with I got the
history of food for you [__]
you guys don't even need to watch the
Food Network anyway there's nothing like
a good cookbook anybody who's done coke
knows when you wake up in the morning
that coke booger that's attached to your
eye on the inside you take that out it's
all crunchy it's like one of those
English [__] caramels you get with
the peanuts on the outside same thing
wrapped up in coke a log you snort an
eight ball plus you get you wake up you
get to 25 hours snots on your nose
one time I burnt this nut and smoked it
you have no idea I was right for two
[__] days nor would never eat
somebody else it's not let's just play
not disgusting but your own good snot
nothing wrong with it anyway who's
talking about snot see I'm trying to
promote love and humanity and you
[__] people talking about snots
that's what I'm talking about you crazy
[__] it's time for a Bonaduce
don't forget working out with uncle Joey
Saturday night ice out 7:30 be there or
be square
we're gonna break down a lot of things
[__] a lot of things
who said bong hit you did okay let's do
it
why [__] around I want to give a shout
out to my people in Miami CMG [__]
jewelry people tremendous they built me
some jewelry some silver jewelry you
gotta see me I look like an NBA player
it's this [__] thinking I gotta wear
a neck brace like a jeweler wear that
[__] change
this [__] pipe he's getting clogged
front i'm always killing here it's that
sticky icky [__] when you got the
sticky icky
there's no [__] around with deke wiki
you know sandy you ever sucked a dinky
wiki it's like smoking a Nicky Wicky
Wicky Wicky whatever the [__] we're
talking about here icky sticky Dickie
wiki whatever the [__] it is your wish
is my command [__] it's all right
look at this I got the first pipe that's
like a margarita
we put THC on the brim who does that for
you
nobody I put mushrooms on the brim last
week who does that nobody I took a
little mushroom I let it dry I [__]
broke it up like a dead bud and me and
Lee smoked that [__] Felicia to
the head she gotta get out of here
it ain't no busy it's that mushroom
[__] powder we gave you death is at
the door [__]
here you go tomorrow I'm doing B reals
podcast was smoking death - mom I'm just
warming up for them all
we're gonna get that type action you
little [__] with your little [__]
vapor pens
cuz suck my dick I'm throwing real vape
at you [__] now it's time for a
few stars who said stars the lycée stars
count them with me
oh these are nice and hard
oh yeah
[Music]
these are nice and hot mmm delicious
nutritious but it went down the wrong
pipe there for a second
it happens will you laughing about [__]
second you got a machine down ass like
that look at that green tongue that's
when yeah the Martians [__] who the
[__] do you think you're dealing with
[__] it's Monday night I told you
we were going deep in this [__]
voodoo cave of life I'm back you
[__] it's gonna be a good week we
got tonight Wednesday night and then
I'll see the rest ears at the ice house
Saturday 7:30 you filthy [__] animals
you know I love you you [__] anyway
worlds theory starts here Tuesday night
that means it's gonna be a game Tuesday
Thursday Friday and Sunday or something
like that what the [__] do I know I
don't know nothing about nothing I'm
just here trying to put the pieces
together you follow me trying to help
you put the pieces together we got a
great show for you tonight we have Led
Zeppelin presents on I'm gonna put my
favorite song off the track here in a
second right now I just want to talk to
you people about particulars you want to
you're good he's good he's I'm saying he
heard the rumor don't even touch the
pipe don't even look at his eyes cuz he
might [__] you up yeah I'm saying well
I'm lucky you'll get stoned I got the
boudoir look little [__] eyes
[__] anyway you don't want a bong
and I'm have to do is cuz that's how I
roll time waits for nobody please don't
eat the stars really bother people over
there sitting there living like a
[__] boat
you know the vamp always it's a vampy
whose cousins with a bumboat using my
fingers don't even burn no more couple
more we said go back to safecracking
yeah I'm saying no fingerprints I don't
know dick I could sit there all night
open up that [__] safe
people don't know about my safe cracking
days don't know dick i'ma buy some I
take pocket days I used to have a
[__] little dummy in the garage your
bells all over them I became a good
pickpocket there for a while but I lost
my touch can you imagine being a pig
packing with these fingers if I can take
a wall out of your pocket with these two
gorilla fingers are you kidding me and
what and I was good at it your goal is
to take a badge off a cop and put it
back on them that's how good you got
again that's when you've graduated you
take it down at night you don't leave it
up you put the dummy in the corner you
take the dress off with the bail so they
think your grandmother's blind that she
needs help to the store
for you micro doses you can suck my dick
if you want to learn how to do a bong it
hit me up next summer July 8th to the
15th his bong and camp 5 days of
non-stop bondage you must sign an
insurance waiver
last year kid went into a coma he's
still in a coma now he's fine he wasn't
squeezing a ball he's been eating
vegetables he's fine but got to sign a
waiver cuz we go training hard here by
12 o'clock you've already done 25 bucks
then you got to run 2 hours to get the
THC out of your system and we start all
over again at 3 o'clock by 7:00 you're
in there in a bed or in your [__]
hospital room with fluids in your arms
that's what part of doing bong at campus
if you want more information hit me up
1-800 bung hit and we'll sign you up on
a list [__] a public service
announcement for uncle Joey industry
sigh rub him my [__] periscope here
yeah I'm saying leave what do we do
already for buying leaves ready for
bonding he didn't rain this weekend but
what are you gonna do I can only leave
the horse to water I cannot make him
drink I've tried he's got bongs he could
bring home to practice we're gonna hit
your heart with this one [__]
this is classic Jimmy Page understand me
oh [__] break out the H [__] if
you got opiates take those to melt them
in the spoon and shoot them in your
[__] foot that's old school right
there Linda Jimmy dropping it well
[Music]
are you [__] kidding me you could
just hear needles right now I just hear
needles it's time for some heroin
[__] go chase that dragon go look
for the nearest Chinese restaurant knock
on the bathroom door three times are we
gonna hit it you didn't know that did
you go to a Chinese restaurant tell them
you want the Yellow Door knocking the
three times little Chinese guy comes out
with acupuncture needles and a little
brown package of China white it's all
over it's all over this is all part of
fungus camp right here we do meditation
we make sure the bad air is on the lungs
so you get the good THC we [__]
around
[Music]
I've got 24 they goalie nadia knows you
you're pulling all the way all the way
there you go Oh what the [__] you think
you're dealing with those are the
[__] that's how you you two could be
doing bong it's like this you two could
be the life of the [__] party you've
been a Deadwood all your [__] life
this is your chance to go to a party and
blow out a bong it and even the girls
that go crazy what the [__] are you
doing you're like that guy at the beach
with the mussels that's it
no more sitting in the corner like a
[__] Hobbit now you could be the life
of the [__] party without even
saying two words how would you like to
go to a party do a bong it and somebody
just get on your you can suck it Jesus
Christ
anyway that's why you get ready for
another bonnet not you you wanna suck a
dick but the pressure is almost done now
we gotta work on the retardation that's
gonna take a long time we worked on the
Moishe got over as moist this weekend
temporarily won a game in 121 dollars
people lost their life voices please
twenty one dollars
[Music]
sure see I'm giving you a little fungus
so there's no misunderstanding slip in
the day if the man is feeling self trejo
you alright let that belly [__] take the
back east the spine
make sure the oxygen is gone go like
this you're Russian oh [__] that's the
one that killed Lincoln that's the one
that killed Lincoln that's called the
wolf poop on it
there you go
his new name is smooth I suggest you
[__] write that down anyway you
know I love it are you [__] kidding
me you don't beep you gotta be the
[__] hang out with Jimmy on this one
listen
[Music]
are you kidding me what do we want to
show up with Justin Timberlake I'll hit
you in the head with a guitar 20 times
you understand we're gonna show up with
[__] Wiz Khalifa will you show up
with that this Jimmy Page [__] he's
standing next to the devil here we are
trying to see the devil he's standing
next to the devil living in Aleister
Crowley's house what have you done
lately nothing so shut the [__] up here
we go are you kidding me and you want to
show up with who Justin Bieber are you
kidding me how days
here we go here we go
[Music]
ople battle of a battle
well if she won couple numbers a couple
edibles and Jimmy Page well what do you
want our life you want to go to
Starbucks and [__] your friends
listen to that [__] nonsense when you
listen to this [__] do bong hits and tap
into your [__] the brains of your
soul all that nonsense and all this [__]
not two joints a little bit of this and
you're back to the [__] wound you
follow me you're back to getting
programmed again you're [__] my loops
anyway youtube.com slash c / Joey Diaz
that's the place to be [__] give
me ten minutes I want you to finish this
[__] listen down
[Music]
you can imagine what do you want so you
want to argue with people by politics
I'm worried about slump and me too Oh
suck my dick okay me too me too nothing
I've got 24 minutes seems like a lap
time are you [__] nuts or what I know
you want to jump out a window but I'm
not letting you gotta deal with this
it's over Joey
but isn't youtube.com / c / Joey Diaz
you [__] figure it out you know I
love you here we go Bam Bam
that's it listen to Jim he ain't
studying going
he ain't going away listen here we go
[Music]
sometime here we go
I'm have to do another bong another
respect that's how I roll
you got to do another bong another
respect not a respect for Jimmy Timmy
and let me I'm saying the better what I
feel it's like this the narcos when they
kept arguing about how many people have
you killed and they go 65 64 but the
little farmers are walking he just hits
them with the car 65 I mean it seems
like a lifetime oh [__] oh [__]
[Music]
when I feel this way listen to the [__]
he ain't going home Jimmy he says [__]
it that batch ain't stopping to the
batch eight swears off like the Battle
of [__] evermore here we go
[Music]
and you want to watch some stupid [__] I
want to binge watch binge watch my dick
go put presents on on YouTube smoke a
joint get back to you uncle Joey in the
morning I love you
don't forget youtube.com slash c / Joey
Diaz and don't forget Saturday night
7:30 working out with uncle Joey
[__] yes the bat magic stars of
death will be there I always got a star
on me sometimes in my ass alone catch
the cops arrest me and I'm saying I love
you [__] stay black